well let's talk about the first time
because I think the story in the film is
you were at a concert yes and you're 22
or something and you saw hoop yeah I was
at the High Sierra music festival and
string cheese incident was playing there
and there are some hoops on the side and
I remember seeing a woman whooping with
just a big plain black hoop and she just
looked so blissful like her whole just
the way she wasn't doing anything but
whooping on her waist and just standing
there but just the way she is moving
with a hoop but just I could feel that
kind of energy of it so um and at the
time I was very afraid to try new things
because I was a perfectionist and the
instant I was like bad at something it
was no forget it I'm not even going to
go there you know but something about
the way that she was moving just really
kind of you know it was bigger than my
fear and so so i tried the hoop and
dropped it a couple times and then it
clicked in and i didn't stop for five
hours because it just was such an
amazing feeling that I'd never
experienced before and that was pretty
much you know the beginning of
everything for me yeah and were you a
dancer at that time because you have
such a graceful dancer's body I am a
natural dancer I was never a trained
dancer but I always loved to dance yeah
I had a traumatic ballet dance
experience when I was six years old and
just like never went back yeah which I'm
grateful now because I have enough of a
type a personality like if I'd become a
ballerina oh my god I probably wouldn't
still be alive or something you know so
I'm glad for that trauma to steer me
away from that path so I could just be
my natural danced herself and you know
not be that so I think I naturally
translate as a dancer with Lu having
been trained and that's why the the hoop
just kind of naturally went that way for
me and where were you in your life at
that time oh gosh I had like no
direction I was just a party girl you
know what was I doing i think i was
working in veterinary clinics because i
always loved animals which i still do
and that was all right but i didn't
really have like you know a mission and
and the hoop was the first thing that
kind of sparked the sense of a mission
because of what i felt with it and also
just
you know that I felt like it was
accessible that other people could feel
that too and you know I think secretly I
just felt a little bit like a weirdo and
I wanted other people to do it too so I
would be less weird yep because I loved
it so much and I was just like oh my god
like I love this little thing like a lot
you know so let's even get other people
to do this so that you know that there's
a few of us I won't feel so weird and
then it just kind of spiraled up from
there but yeah
you